beaucoup disent nouveau cabinet était
attendu avec impatience pour en parler
je joins nos collaborateurs d'achat et à
toronto daniel lui était à ottawa
bonsoir à vous de michel on ne pouvait
pas être avec nous malheureusement
toujours à cela bonsoir alors ce cabinet
est ce qui est à la hauteur des attentes
parce qu'elle était très élevé ces
attentes qu'en pensez vous daniel bah
écoutes je pense que je serai trudeau a
fait tout ce qu'il fallait faire tout ce
qu'on attendait de lui
parité hommes femmes plusieurs femmes
dans des postes très importants
équilibre régional absolument
scrupuleusement respecté une grande
place aux aux minorités visé bref il a
tout fait ce qu'il devait faire
est-ce qu'il a atteint la perfection
vous savez atteindre la perfection c'est
une chose à maintenir c'est une touche
beaucoup quand même c'est lui a demandé
beaucoup gouvernement polonais à 84 il
pensait lui aussi avoir atteint la
perfection et un an plus tard ya des
ministres qui devait démissionner parce
qu'ils étaient soit incompétent soit
qu'ils avaient fait des conneries là
peut-être le point le point qui m'a le
plus surpris moi c'est face aux affaires
étrangères je viens d'écouter avec vous
il va jouer et c'est très important je
pense qu'il va jouer un double rôle de
mentor d'abord auprès de justin trudeau
sur les affaires internationales
parce que monsieur dior a une très bonne
vision des choses on l'a vu tout à
l'heure et deuxièmement au niveau de
l'environnement aussi auprès de la
nouvelle ministre catherine mais kana
c'est lui et c'est pas innocent de la
part de justin trudeau ccfa diot qui
sera président du comité du cabinet sur
l'environnement autrement dit c'est
peut-être lui qui va par derrière sur et
toutes les ficelles bah on verra mais en
tout cas je peux vous dire que le sujet
le passionne toujours d'achat vous
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce cabinet
et si stéphane dion est le joker des
libéraux vient pour lui écoute très bon
ministre des affaires étrangères je
pense me suis dit on pas qu'on va faire
une bonne job aussi c'est un politicien
très expérimenté trudeau a mis une
combinaison d'expérience et de nouveaux
visages c'est un bon cabinet écoute on
peut pas dire que ces gens là ne sont
pas qualifiés il ya certaines
nominations comme monsieur morneau aux
finances on va voir
il est pas un politicien
une grande tâche devant 10 est un expert
c'est sûr politicienne nouvelle
cependant et l'est toujours dans le
monde politique dans son ancien poste en
colombie britannique avec les premières
nations comme chef est ce que c'était
une surprise pour vous tâche a quand
même une femme leader autochtone dont le
poste la justice et non pas au ministère
des affaires autochtones justement non
je pense pas du tout actuellement parce
que je pense des deux postes vont être
reliés dans le sens qu'il ya beaucoup de
questions autochtones doivent être
réglés qui couchent à la justice alors
dans un sens cela je pense était
important de mettre quelqu'un dans la
justice qui les comprend mais pas
nécessairement pour négocier dans le
poste de d'affaires autochtone de mettre
quelqu'un de la communauté dans ce pot
cela parce que peut-être on vous
l'époque semble y avoir de conflit ou
quoi que ce soit je pense que trudeau a
bien fait et écoute je pense que c'est
difficile de critiquer le cabinet comme
il est sauf que moi je pense que
beaucoup de de symbolisme et de pilleurs
comme on dit en anglais qui a été fait
autour du fait qu'il ya tant de femmes
où est la parité
daniel quand même emmanuel le disais
tout à l'heure
beaucoup de femmes oui la parité mais
dans les postes importants il reste
quand même y'a quand même ministère de
la justice et demie cerveau
environnement ces deux ministères très
important et qui vont occuper beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup du temps de ce
gouvernement là c'est pas c'est bon
c'est pas les finances c'est pas un
commerce commerce international c'est
une femme aussi qui est là alors c'est
pas c'est pas je trouve que c'est pas
juste de dire qu'elles sont dans des
postes secondaires
il y en a au moins trois ou quatre ans
des postes extrêmement important as qui
est ce qu'elle méritait d'être là si
vous regardez leur feuille de route
ce que j'ai fait cet après midi une par
une comparer avec les hommes elles n'ont
absolument rien à leur envier
6e les hommes ont été laissés de côté
parce qu'il faudrait faire de la place
aux femmes
j'imagine que je lance le chef de police
de toronto bill blair ou le colonel à la
retraite dans la région de tahoua
monsieur le sli routes européennes
on aurait pu être là sauf que si vous
regardez les deux les deux ministres qui
sont allés possible convoitait ces deux
hommes alors je pense que
égalité elle est là parce que comme le
dit justin trudeau on est en 2015 mais
parce qu'aussi ses fins 900 soit
compétent passer ça fait c'est pas exact
d'achat quand même que ces femmes ne
sont très compétentes
oui et pas de doute qu elles sont
compétentes sauf que le point que mais
c'est tout mais trudeau aurait pu les
mettre là sans faire un graphe la flèche
sur le fait qu'ilyas parité c'est
quelque chose qui voulait être
l'histoire de la journée il a réussi on
en parle même ici mais la réalité c'est
que beaucoup de ces postes-là étaient
déjà occupés par des femmes on on s'en
souvient pu y avait deux ministres de la
santé femmes deux ministres
environnement femme transporte femmes à
faire d'approvisionnement preuve de
courtoisie en anglais femmes il y avait
plein de femmes dans ces cabinets 12 fin
effectivement nommés par messieurs
harper mais c'est trudeau un ami a nommé
le pourcentage est plus grand parce que
monsieur trudeau a réduit la taille du
cabinet est lui-même a pris deux postes
des affaires intergouvernementales ainsi
que genève pour lui même et il a fait du
ministère de la statut de la femme
un ministère un indépendant ce qui
n'était pas dans les anciens gouvernants
alors oui la parité oui mais c'est pas
un énorme changement dans l'histoire
leurs termes de chiffres qu'on avait
avant daniel il n'y aura pas de
lieutenant québécois ça vous surprend
ce ne sont pas non et ça ne me déçoit
pas non plus le poste de lieutenant
québécois s'ils vont remonter dans le
temps et dans mon cas je remonte jusqu'à
1980 avec pierre elliott trudeau et
avant lui joe clark
c'est un poste de patronage de
favoritisme on est là pour faire plaisir
à bien des gens pour distribuer des
cadeaux on est là surtout pour organiser
des élections pour trouver des candidats
bref à ça peut être joué par plusieurs
personnes
je pense pas que je perçois soit très
important je pense pas que le québec va
y perd beaucoup en n'ayant pas de
lieutenant politique à ottawa
bon alors il ya bull plusieurs priorités
on le dit beaucoup ces temps ci a
beaucoup de pain sur la planche
il va devoir consacrer ses énergies à
coire d'abord d'achat mais premièrement
il doit s'attaquer à la question fiscale
changer les impôts la taux d'imposition
pour rennes pour les curieux chez le bc
pour les dépliants de la classe moyenne
il doit faire ça avant la fin de l'année
il doit aussi s'attaquer à la question
autochtone
le dôme à la demande pour une enquête
dans le code et femmes qui ont été tués
les femmes un aborigène ainsi que
probablement la question des réfugiés le
25 mille réfugiés
je lui souhaite bonne chance quand il a
fait la promesse au début ses amis
c'était un peu plus réaliste mais même
là aujourd'hui en novembre je sais pas
comment monsieur mac callum en
immigration
valve a fermé ça va être ça c'est une
énorme tâche je vous disais qu'il en
avait parlé aujourd'hui la au cabinet il
va falloir que techniquement et fasse
des miracles pour en faire venir autant
au report par mois de volonté mais mais
techniquement comment on organise tous
en commun estime anne au canada
il vole commence quasiment falloir un
mur qui vont commencer mais je pense pas
qu'il fût serein à 25 milles avant les
fêtes
l'aide médicale à mourir aussi alors
combien de temps peut durer la lune de
miel h à bombay et qu être regarder la
couverture aujourd'hui et quads y avait
3000 personnes qui se sont présentées
un vidéo aujourd'hui c'est clair que la
population canadienne est très emballée
de monsieur trudeau et les médias aussi
ça va durer pendant plus longtemps je
pense que la lune de miel l'habitude
moi je dirais non mais si les promesses
si les choses vont pour vous même à
l'économie ça va commencer à tourner
mais je parle des gens vont lui donner
le bénéfice du doute plus longtemps que
d'habitude
daniel lejeune changement qui souffle
oui non et écouter la lune de miel plus
heureux boutin si comme le dit sachant
n'y a pas d'erreur majeure et va durer
encore plus longtemps six premiers mines
et sur l'eau d'abord lé 8 à la hauteur
des attentes
il a quatre voyages à l'étranger s'il
fait joe clark de lui même perd ses
valises se cogne la tête sur le bord de
l'avion
sa réputation peut que peut partir il
peut diminuer très rapidement mais bon
il a il a de l'expérience il ya ses
fonctions
au total et non écoutés à la lune de
miel peut durer celle de fait des
couilles a duré assez longtemps
il est encore assez haut dans les
sondages malgré tout malgré tout ce
qu'il a fait le ses rites et cetera ci a
pas d'erreur majeure et ya pas de grande
déception ça faisait un bout de temps
mais pas indéfiniment sans police et qui
a rien qui devrait définir voilà merci
beaucoup à vous deux pour ses
commentaires là à chaud après cette
grosse journée quand même merci beaucoup